okay so the brand new spider-man noah
home trailer has some pretty wild easter
eggs in it whilst it didn't end the
debate over whether toby mcguire and
andrew garfield are in the movie there
were lots of hints and mistakes in it
that hinted at them being there marvel
trailers are famous for misleading
people and even in spider-man ones we've
seen how costumes have been switched out
for the final cuts this trailer is no
different and originally when moments
from this movie were shown in empire
magazine we saw tom holland wearing the
red and black suit only to now learn
that he'll be wearing the integrated one
plus that tom holland reaction to it
kind of gave away that things were
missing herbs
where's the this is all my fault i can't
save everyone where's the this is all my
fault i can't save everything
where's the yeah you better not finish
that sentence you little punk now in the
new look there's several special effects
that stand out like a sore thumb and it
has the entire trailer looking like this
at points throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down each of the
special effects that could confirm toby
and andrew in the film as well as some
of the cool easter eggs that we've
noticed since watching it for the 900th
time now the biggest indicator comes in
a shot that i'm sure you've seen all
over the internet at this point and this
moment happens when tom holland's
spider-man leaps towards electro sandman
and the lizard though the english
versions of the trailer cut out before
anything was revealed the brazilian one
has a moment in it in which the lizard
gets kicked in the face by an invisible
force whilst this could be ant-man or
john cena what's likely going on here is
that they removed one of the spider-man
from the scene and if i had to hazard a
guess i'd say that this is andrew
garfield garfield and the lizard had a
rivalry in the amazing spider-man movie
and therefore it just makes sense that
he'd be the one taking on the villain
now because of this we can also guess
that tom and andrew won't be facing off
against three villains themselves and if
you look at the way that the shot is set
up it seems like the bad guys are going
towards their own targets typically in
films when you have a final showdown you
get the same amount of villains as there
are heroes so that you can have people
facing off against their counterparts
personally i think that the tom holland
spider-man that we see is actually toby
maguire and he will be leaping towards
sandman though he can't see who electro
is heading towards i would imagine that
this is tom holland's version and then
everyone is going to be going toe to toe
against someone sure electro and andrew
garfield also have a big history because
he forgot his birthday but they have
changed up the design for jamie foxx
whereas the others remain the same as in
their original films i think that this
has kind of been done for the reason
that he's very much an mcu version from
an alternate universe whereas the lizard
and sandman could be from films that
we've already seen
if you look at other parts in the
trailer it also seems like electro is
fighting someone off screen as he
doesn't chase after tom even though he
would if he was the only spider-man a
shout out to eric voss at new rockstars
for pointing out that there's a moment
which a piece of cap shield actually
warps as if someone is jumping off it
potentially this could be another
spider-man and the vfx artist didn't
erase the bend and warping motion that
the shield had now another interesting
mistake seems to happen just as mj falls
backwards off the scaffolding though ned
reaches out to her there also seems to
be a ghostly arm on the left hand side
of the shot it almost seems like this
has a body attached to it that's been
erased through vfx and whoever did it
better start applying for jobs and a new
identity come monday because kevin feige
don't miss now for the next part of the
video i will be showing some of the
apparent leaked footage of andrew
garfield so if you've managed to avoid
this then well done on missing one of
the biggest spoilers on the web but i
will find you and i will spoil you also
if you're enjoying the video so far i'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up and
make sure you subscribe for breakdowns
like this each and every day if you're
new here then welcome to the heavy
spoiler show i'm your host paul aka your
friendly neighborhood spoiler man now
let's get into the rest of the video
okay so earlier in the year there was
some leaked footage released that
apparently showed andrew garfield
gripping some scaffolding similar to
what we see in this shot if you saw the
leaked images that john can't be posted
out you'll know that the scaffolding
played a big part in that too so it
seems like the leaks are indeed true now
that we've seen this trailer i would
actually love it if these scenes were
stitched together and after andrew
appeared here he then jumped to save mj
along with tom holland he cast your mind
back to the amazing spider-man 2 his
biggest failure was letting the love of
his life die and if he helped to save mj
then this would somewhat redeem gwen
stacy's death the shots are so similar
and not only do the moments line up with
tom holland's worst nightmare and far
from home but they also called back to
the death of andrew's love so i think at
this moment that it just makes sense for
andrew to swoop in and this is a very
popular fan theory at the moment and
actually love for him to travel into a
universe where she didn't die at the end
of the movie and he could kind of get a
second chance at life like steve rogers
i've boosted the brightness on this shot
too and through doing that though it
does lose some of the color you can kind
of make out that it might be an arm with
a hand and fingers attached to it other
possibilities are that it's just a rope
with nuts in it and many have said that
it's actually just one used in
construction situations but i'm a
believer and also an idiot now another
moment that makes it seem like they
switched out the costumes happens for a
split second in the trailer when we
watch spider-man swinging through the
construction site the eyes on the mask
look exactly like toby maguire's one and
if we look at this mask in another shot
you can see how different they appear
one is angles and a more rigid design or
as the other doesn't so i'd be surprised
if this isn't actually toby mcguire now
as for the other easter eggs that have
been found since you might have noticed
that when spider-man goes to tackle
electro they can actually make out that
mj and ned are playing on a screen on
his chest i don't know if this is a
hologram or just a screen attached to
him but i actually think that it might
be a phone and that peter is currently
face timing them i love how it's sort of
tied back to ned being the guy in the
chair and it's awesome that they're
gonna be watching the fight play out too
if you look closely you can actually see
that there's duct taped on his suit
holding this in place and this is of
course also used by electrical engineers
quite a lot you might also catch that
there's actually wires sticking out the
suit as well and this might be because
he's outfitted it so that electro can't
damage him this actually happened in the
comics as well and peter built a special
suit for fighting his electrical enemy
so i'd love to see that brought across
here electro also has an arc reactor on
his chest and shouts chris from 3c films
for pointing that out even though i hate
that son of a [ __ ] now since the
trailer's release we've also had a tv
spot drop that shows more of the moment
that doctor strange traps peter i
absolutely love how he makes the wall
crawler use his own webs to trap himself
and he pretty much portaled that
[ __ ] strange then pulls him in
and pushes him so hard that he astral
projects out of his body which is of
course a move that we saw the ancient
one pull on strange and also hulk in
avengers end game peter says that it's
one of the coolest things that's ever
happened to him but that he shouldn't
ever do it again now i kind of have a
theory that the way peter is able to
escape from this has a lot to do with
his spider sense and as this makes his
body react automatically sometimes he's
able to break the hold and still move
peter often does this off instinct alone
so i think that would make sense as to
why strange lets him go now lastly i
want to talk about the explosion seen in
the trailer firstly we see jay jonah
jameson who's wearing very similar
clothes to what he had on in spider-man
3. we actually get a lot of moments at
this building namely the sandman and
electro storm that we see happening
there's also a bit in which doc ock is
blasted out of a window and there is
potential that he's actually turned good
at this point and he's trying to fight
the villains other shots we see are that
peter dives at a pumpkin bomb and he
catches it in the air as it explodes
this explosion actually happens though
and he's unable to stop it however his
suit and superpowers might have saved
him unfortunately someone who might not
have been saved as aunt may who we do
see inside this building if you look at
her hand she has a strange device in it
and this could be what's used to warp
the villains to the sanctorum prison it
was reported by big screen leaks that
the magic we see on the gauntlets is
actually an infused web shooter that
allows him to zap the bad guys back to
the basement i kind of feel like may may
be rushing to peter to give him this
equipment so that he can shoot the green
goblin back there and unfortunately
she's gonna get caught in the blast this
would explain why happy is outside
looking devastated and why peter is out
in the rain looking completely destroyed
and may dying would actually make a lot
of sense as well as in the comics after
peter's identity is revealed hitmen go
after him and they end up shooting may
in the process though people think mj
will die i don't think that's the case
as we see her and peter kissing in the
sunlight whilst he's wearing the
integrated suit i think that this likely
happens at the end of the movie after
the statue of liberty scene anyway
that's all the extra stuff i thought was
worth talking about after the initial
breakdown you absolute sucker got you
here for another video your mug but
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
so make sure you comment below and let
me know also i just want to give a big
thank you for getting me to
000 subscribers i'm absolutely blown
away by all the support and i can't
believe there's that many people out
there with great taste in youtube
channels thank you for sticking with me
and i hope to see you at the million one
of which we better get there before i
get cancelled for calling you all
suckers you sucker now if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our full breakdown of the
trailer which will be linked on screen
right now it was trending number two in
the world so it must be good or posted
out really fastly and youtube just
wanted something to put on the front
page but make sure you go watch it right
after this if not then thanks for
sitting through the video i've been paul
i'll see you in the next one take care
peace